pegi 16 ou quand j'étais jeune j'ai
trouvé un louveteau orphelins dans la
forêt près de notre ferme
je pensais qu'en instaurant des règles
des limites précises qui pourrait
maîtriser la puissance de la bête
quelques mois plus tard à la chasse le
louveteau qui avait grandi s'est
retourné contre moi
nous essayons de réparer les dégâts que
les avengers ont causé il ya des années
les inhumains sont malades
un pouvoir illimité c'est dangereux
voire mortels tu as la chance d'être en
vie
palais kamala là ils viennent peut aider
je vais tenter ma chance et si vous
aviez été piégé je pense que vous
devriez regarder
monsieur stark pourrait nous aider oh
désolé tu es qui toi que voilà j'espère
qu'elle vaut le lourd il a enfermé cap
dans la salle du réacteur et il a tenté
de saboter les chimères bordel
vous avez tous complètement perdu
l'esprit ltd ou quand ça a commencé à
mal tourner et c'est notre faute à nous
tous et tu penses que le monde se porte
mieux sans nous oui ça a toujours été
ton problème tu as peur de qui tu es ce
que tu es
exactement ce que tu attends tu veux
vous ne parviendrait pas à contenir la
vague inévitable progrès tigers
[Musique]
le pouvoir ne peut être contre
nous sommes
t3 y est
je débarrasserait la terre des super
pouvoirs
même si je dois donner ma fille
[Musique]
ça devient de plus en plus bizarre
plus de stations